and please viewed by 200 between
students based on mr. Bachmann provided
894 plate Netflix but ideas concerns
well thanks a lot and throw of our
inflames the moist or about ideas about
your out of the things that people like
about some ideas most of our idea that
plagues are about creating courses I've
learned to talk about some sports
this area team we charge card with the
series in politics which shows pathways
it's Romania and it will to statement
trust myself warm and fight ground
because this is because majority of both
legs were were round sports and
Recreation hosted was really poignant as
a very sort of beautiful scope they have
also an apartment sodas easy access to
sports ground and a parking lot we have
chosen to put a disabled pop because I
personally think it is very important
and it is in trouble community the
question we need to think about head on
old people happen is also a public
toilet that is essential and schools
grounds
the only concern was it is actually a
symmetry right next door and so some
people including myself was worried
people
many disrespect this in our trade rules
might require defeats an anoxic window
where some items and arranged by open
pipe fittings which is Felicity shimmer
decided that we would decide that
disabled in technical training path we
will select the idea of having a big
remain stagnant in place because there's
mom in front of him free but it'll give
the people with most privileged lights
adjusted to stop an inner shine it will
also get people that at a time of those
spaces a place to make it great here we
also have to protect cheese continually
from Indian for entrances for this day
the only concern we can't resist the
detention was right for us we have
another card that will have it go ahead
at a sample product as well as the 80s
we have a picnic table we're under a
long time riding you can take these yer
and see sitting down as you can take
them to a favorite sandwich over here we
have a relaxing love not like those
friends your honor mental journey or
just enjoying the scenery in our wooden
is a distance away from the hardwood was
a student studying for the library lost
facilities certain rockets and she's
shopping
so we also feel connected hi boy or do
you still it's also inside for quietly
high school so what about students are
clothing it even clergymen we think that
was plain the area is starting to make a
great image of the returned development
the entertainment areas in rural areas
actually write our idea business we want
to mention a non-student nila
who helped us with a lot of the
algorithm thank you for listening